[Music]
she is such a good mom and she's really
tried to now prioritize just time with
family
she's taking time out with of course
chandler her husband and
her beautiful daughter grace i'm already
trying to teach you how to play the
guitar it's one of my passions
trying to be the fun uncle funkel robert
the 17 year old is also hoping to pass
on to grace the irwin family's love for
wildlife
in fact he's now gone from training
crocs to swimming with sharks
i got to actually swim with sharks and
have them about this far away from my
head
sharks can sense your heart rate so how
do you keep your emotions
in check the the problem wasn't the the
fear factor it's more that
my heart was going so fast out of pure
joy and excitement you know
robert's actually following in the
footsteps of his dad
steve who also swam with sharks nearly
two decades ago
check out his teeth he always said
diving with sharks particularly with
great whites of course
it's the most moving experience that
you'll ever have
sadly we're nearing the 15th anniversary
of steve's death
after being stung by a poisonous
stingray on his adventure
robert swims with giant manta rays which
are harmless to humans
manta rays are the same class of fish as
sharks
you can share robert honoring his
father's legacy in
crikey is shark week sunday on the
discovery channel
to me in my life that's that's what i
want to do more than anything else i
just want to make him proud you know
you